the mother of the two British Israeli
sisters killed in an attack in the West
Bank on Friday has died you see the two
sisters there who lost their lives let's
bring in our Middle East correspondent
Alistair bunkel this afternoon so a very
sad development it seems Annie
a very sad development just to recap
this was a terrorist attack that took
place in the West Bank in the Jordan
Valley on Friday she was traveling in
her car with two of her daughters her
husband and their other siblings were in
the car in front of them and they were
on their way to a holiday in the Galilee
District over the Passover period when a
car a car opened fire on them and then
rammed them off the road now the two
daughters Maya and Rina D were killed at
the scene but Lucy the 48 year old
mother was airlifted to hospital close
to Jerusalem she was in a critical
condition we're told by the hospital
that the teams fought for her life over
the past few days in the trauma unit the
operating room and the Intensive Care
Unit unfortunately the hospital
announcement says despite intensive and
unceasing efforts due to her fatal
injury the team has to determine her
death today and the statement adds that
the family have decided to donate her
organs in order to save the lives of
others while the funeral of the two
daughters Maya and Rina was held in the
village where they lived close to
Jerusalem just in the West Bank
yesterday afternoon it was attended by
hundreds of more or less friends and
families it's a very emotional affair
but this was the second of two Terror
attacks when it starts the first but
there were two Terror attacks in Israel
on the same day last week the other one
was in Tel Aviv where a Neuer from Rome
was hit by a car that drove off the road
and killed him and wounded some others
so two moments of extreme violence and
sadness in what was a very disruptive
and violent week here
yeah there's so many things indeed our
Middle East correspondent Alistair
bunkel bringing us up to date with
developments the mother of these two
girls the two British Israeli sisters
killed in an attack in the West Bank on
Friday has herself now died